somebody told me I was a very rich
person mm-hmm and I got maybe a dollar
in my pocket you know so they said
Google yourself right now what is he
worth seventy four million dollars
congratulations boy that makes you feel
rich you know but it's kind of like
Trump it was all tax write-off oh no I
never got the money
you know right I gave it away you know
if you don't if you don't grow up with
money you really don't know how to keep
it you know they say that now I do find
it hard to be responsible with money
have you been
have you made some errors well you know
first of all they overwhelm you with the
amount you know I got criticized for
turning down a million dollars on
several things for the patchy and rich
man poor man - I wouldn't do it I said
it sure sure everyone Shaw got a right
rich man poor men - oh no no no we'll
get some television writers I said well
you know I'm not gonna do it you know
unless Arwen writes a sequel to his book
which he did do called beggar man thief
and there was a series that called
beggar man thief so there is actually
Richmond apartment - mayor man thief and
Hamelin and show off of it just over the
controversy of doing - because they
called me in first to tell me that it
wasn't gonna be three - our movies they
well I got a didn't a half-hour shows
and call it a miniseries and you know I
wasn't old enough to really give him a
lot of [ __ ] but I said you know that's
not how my agenda but that's your agenda
okay well they're making a miniseries
don't think did you keep putting little
climaxes in there and I would say so
yeah
yeah they could cut it up but they said
they had it me in any room he cuts up
wonderful I said what he just trying to
stretch the product out as far as you
can then I went back to work then they
called me in and they said look the
offers a million dollars we want you to
play your son you know come back and
we're and Parmenter I said to Frank
prices affray I died at the end
Who am I gonna play he said what you
said come back as your son I don't think
so Frank yeah and those prophetic words
were spoken he said this I'll tell you
something and tell you finish your
obligation television you'll not work
film in this town Wow I'll just have to
take my chances more like Frank I walked
out did you work from in that town yeah
and then town had called me from
Universal who's ahead film
I said Jaden and you're I'm sorry I
can't take this call he said why I won't
offer you a three-picture deal all I
said well yeah but I can't work for you
is why it's a while Frank Tony I'm
telling finish he don't believe that
[ __ ]